um why don't you tell them about how you
broke the woman's deadlifting record
with ease
um yeah okay so this is going back like
three and a half years ago time flies in
February 2019 I posted a now famous or
inFAMOUS video on Twitter of me doing a
the video was a 230 kilo deadlift and I
said something along the lines of I keep
hearing about how biological men have no
strength advantage over women in 2019 so
watch me destroy the British women's
deadlift record without trying PS
identified as a woman whilst lifting the
weight don't be a bigot
um at the time I posted that I had 18
000 followers on Twitter so I thought it
was going to get a couple laughs you
know a few retweets whatever very
quickly I realized that I had done
something I didn't exactly know what it
was but the video Hit 10 000 views in
about 10 minutes and it just kept
growing and growing by the time I went
to bed that night it was 300 000 woke up
in the morning half a million hit a
million later that day and it just kept
going and going and going at one point I
remember this I was gaining about a
hundred followers an hour
for weeks on end so I hit 20K 30k why is
it kept kept on going I mean today I
think I'm at I don't know 860 000
something Twitter followers but this
video put me on the map for millions of
people including some very high profile
people like Joe Rogan whose podcasts
I've now been on twice uh Ben Shapiro
Candace Owens Tucker Carlson Piers
Morgan all these media figures around
the world and then so many people who
have ended up becoming fan supporters
and followers of what I do
um main thing I actually do is making
music I'm also an author I run a podcast
called real talk with zooby I'm a public
speaker so it's been a wild ride over
these last few years but that is how it
all started with that deadlift video so
to this day if you if you Google search
British women's deadlift record I think
my name still comes up right at the
beginning and my Wikipedia page so
no it looks like no woman's been able to
break that record just yet so there we
are
um so this inspired our topic today
which is our modern women men
[Laughter]
um and we're going to react to a clip
from Matt Walsh and I just want to get
you know since we have a full panel full
of women today
um
everyone's take on it yeah
there you go
with the fluidity of these things
how do I know if if I'm a woman you know
I
that's a great question I like scented
candles yeah I've watched Sex in the
City yeah
um yeah so how do I know yeah Matt that
question right there like that question
is
like when it's asked with a lot of
curiosity right that's the beginning of
a lot of people's like gender identity
development Journeys if my mom who gave
birth to me is
a woman
and my wife is a woman though I haven't
asked her
maybe I should
um
but they're all women and also the boy
who sits down with you and says I think
I'm a girl
actually is one then then what is a
woman
um
[Laughter]
I don't care if you think you're a sheep
dog
and you come into my store it don't
matter to me just don't come in and try
to shove that [ __ ] down my throat if it
makes someone feel better what about
their feelings I don't give a [ __ ] about
them
they're on a Star Wars universe
Jar Jar Binks
pansexual do you think
transgender
um
why why that why would I that's the
truth
well it ain't true
you're not a gender Studies major or are
you no no okay how do you know that
you're a man how do I know that I'm I
guess because I got it there
so what
what is a woman
why do you ask the question
I just really like to know
what do you think the answer to that
question is
well I'm asking that's why I came to a
college professor who who's
this is your this is what you do
what other kinds of answers have you got
a lot of like this where you're where
you're not answering I've got a lot of
that so I think it's interesting that
you that you say that some of the people
you've you've interviewed have been I'm
reluctant to answer it and I think that
has a lot to do with the way the
questions that preceded it and the the
way that you've conducted yourself in
the interview how have I conducted
myself
how do you think you've conducted
yourself
beta
I just really don't want to answer the
questions do you I I came today very
willing and enthusiastic about answering
questions about women's and gender
sexuality studies which is what you
wanted to do you want to answer
questions about women's studies and so
shouldn't the the first answer you
should be able to provide is what
exactly is a woman well it's it for me
it's it's actually a really simple
answer and that's a person who
identifies as a woman but what are they
identifying as as a woman so what is
that
as a woman
do you know what a circular definition
is
I do
it's sort of like what you're doing
right now where a woman is is a woman
because you're seeking what we would
call in my field of work and essentially
shout out to Matt Walsh
so my first question for the panel
it's what is a woman
and why and why
don't they want to answer it and so you
can start and then go all the way around
okay uh I believe that a woman is
um a human being that is born with
certain areas of their body and their
mind that is different is completely
different to a man that's the best way
I've never even been asked that question
but that's the best way I can describe
it
um
we
I believe a woman has a different mind
to a man
um a different wiring and a completely
different body and we also have a
completely different reproductive system
okay should I go last or should I go now
yeah you can go now or do you want to go
I'd like to hear the other answers okay
okay then you can go first
um to me a Woman by definition would be
someone who has two X chromosomes uh and
possesses her vagina as a standard okay
that's what I'd say
oh my God I don't know because it can't
be based on biological factors because
like women it doesn't matter anyway if
you have a vagina you know what I mean
so I'm like
I guess a woman is someone that feels
like a woman if you feel because I can't
even say something what if I when the
record stands as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible